you are so funny uh
and and so sharp tweeting about our
president often
and we're in this moment right now uh
where of course
things have gotten to a level of
insanity it does really feel like
it feels like we're living in death wish
three like
the streets are you know but you are
still seem to have
kind of an optimistic attitude about the
situation we're in right now which is
which fascinates me you and i are big
history buffs you've caught me reading
robert carroll's
lbj books and all of you know all of uh
uh reagan land and nixon land and the
invisible bridge and all those
so i i try to look to history for
comfort but what i'm also realizing
is trump as bad as he is
uh you know he is the boomers last
temper tantrum before they die
that's what we're looking at every
generation as they get older
and they start to be realize they're
being phased out
the boomers were like we were the
cutting edge we were the
disruptors and now they're seeing no
there's there's
gen x there's millennials there's gen y
there so so they picked
what's the last thing we can do to have
a tantrum and it was
donald trump the most awful bloated
white dude and as bad as he is i always
tell my gen x friends and i try to tell
millennials or whatever like i'm out
talking to people but like
like as bad as this tantrum is just know
that whatever our gen x tantrum is going
to be even worse when we are
when we are in our 60s and 70s we are
going to have some crazy tantrum
where we know we were the cool ones and
god knows who we're gonna put up there
it's gonna be eddie vetter
or janine garofalo and and i love those
two
i love janine she's a friend but
she would agree with me she'd be a
terrible president she would take
my house and go uh you know what i'm
just not showing up today i you know i
don't feel good i'm not doing it or
eddie vettel would be like
i'm just doing all the all of the white
house business is going to be done here
on the at the beach i'm just going to be
sitting by my
board and i shudder to think what our
temper tantrum's going to look like
you know i just love the idea of uh
eddie vetter giving his state of the
union speech
but we can't understand him because he
says it the way he sings
and it's like
oh [ __ ] lady
the first thing he'll say is first off
this is all bs
okay do we all understand that all of
this is nonsense we shouldn't even be
here man
and so like it'll just be oh it's to be
a bad tantrum
it's going to be bad well make sure i
mention these things i love everything
is available to stream on netflix
uh and do you feel free to put on the
closed captioning function and i'll be
gone in the dark
uh is fantastic it airs sundays at 10
o'clock p.m
on hbo and it's available to stream
on hbo max and uh
it is a lovely tribute and a fascinating
fascinating story so well told
patton i'm thinking about you i'm here
at largo and uh we're holding down the
fort
i've actually put a mattress in one of
the two small dressing rooms
on the floor you know what i went to the
mattress
yeah and so uh and and there's part of
me that that when things get back to
normal and comedians come back i'm gonna
insist they keep the mattress on the
floor and say that's the conan o'brien
memorial madras
yeah well you know way high over your
left shoulder there's a pinata shaped
like me
i see it right here there it is oh my
god
yeah there's also a i think i showed
this online but there's a um
she's a beautiful beautiful woman we all
love her but there's an absolutely
horrifying crocheted pillow
sarah silverman on it which haunts my it
haunts my dreams
it's it's truly haunting i think mark
cohen made that
and uh oh god yeah look at that
it's this is a crime scene it is
yeah sarah we love you and you're
absolutely gorgeous
this i don't think anybody looks good as
a crocheted pillow no
and also a crocheted pillow with
someone's face on it
that's like found in ed gein's house
it says serial killer written all over
it
oh it's amazing a lot of um stuff here
uh
i'm really i think i need to spend a
night here since there's a mattress here
i'm going to probably sleep here one
night
um conan at night all that stuff comes
alive
i'm just letting you know you don't want
to spend the night there it's something
else
it all comes to life and they all just
have sex with each other
i was going to say they have a creepy
dance party to collaborate music and you
went right to
they have an orgy yeah i'm sorry you
know
sorry sorry maybe it starts with your
vision and ends with mine